i'd like to thank the audience for the
opportunity to present today
my name is jamie elliott i'm director of
global business development
and i focus and specialize on
pharmacogenetics platform development
and implementation
for thermo fisher scientific and today
i'll be giving an overview on some of
the criteria for platform to
selection in pharmacogenetics
specifically as it applies to
applied research
so while the inclusion of pgx content is
highly desired
across a broad spectrum of use cases
such as high content applications
in basic research described in the right
hand or left hand side of the slide
my talk will focus really on applied
testing use cases described in the right
hand side of the slide i'm going to
highlight two specific
technologies specifically a microarray
technologies and qpcr-based technologies
and the factors that
impact technology selection
in pharmacogenetics application
i certainly don't need to tell this
audience that
platform robustness is is the key
consideration among the other factors
that i'll talk about today
drugs are genes involved in drug
metabolism
are some of the most structurally
complex genes in the genome
and assaying them is also a complicated
technological undertaking and so for
that reason
[Music]
platform robustness is critical um and
uh
is a is the primary uh critical
consideration
for technology selection
i'm gonna look through or talk through
selection criteria such as the panel
size
the required application i'll define
what i mean by application here briefly
custom versus fixed content will focus
mostly on customization of content
sample through put our time to results
and cost
per sample is these primary selection
criteria for these platform technologies
and i thought it'd be interesting to use
a use case that i think is
well known to this audience and that is
the cms recent decision for a local
coverage decision
for pharmacogenetics implementation for
routine testing
and i'm selecting this use case one
because i think it's of great interest
to this group
but also because it highlights the three
application areas
or the diversity of application areas
that pharmacogenetics demands
and here i'll define application in
genotyping copy number variation and
we'll talk about that in the context of
sip 2d6 analysis
and then hla analysis i bring this up
because in certain technologies
these can be addressed singularly in a
workflow
in other technologies they maybe
need to be addressed using different
application
technologies to support a full panel and
and yet each system that i'll define has
a
core value and so you'll want to assess
a platform selection and content
in the context of the type of panel you
want to
deploy the time frame that you need to
get results back to your constituents or
results back to your end user
cost is a key driver and certainly
your ability to customize that content
on an ongoing basis
i'll give an overview i think in kind of
a summary
of what i just described and i'll do
that in the context of the three
technology the two technologies that
i'll be describing and the three
uh panel-based use cases that i'll be
going through in the remainder of the
talk i'm going to start with a pcr
based technology in open array
and i'll define this as a core
genotyping platform
with copy number as a separate workflow
albeit on the same instrument
i see an application use case of less
than 120 markers
a time to results for just genotyping
would be as as
quickly as one day and genotyping with
copy number in two days
for the microarray based applications
i'll be talking about a relatively high
density
uh platform offering in pharmaco
scan which is about 4 000
variants covered over about a thousand
genes
a single workflow that can address copy
number genotyping
and hla in formats of 24 samples or 96
samples per plate
but a workflow of up to three and a half
days
and then a more targeted panel in
pharmacofocus also a microarray based
technology
covering again genotyping copper number
variation in hla in a single workflow
but as saying 2 000 markers
across about 150 genes but in in
a plate densities of 96 samples or 384
samples and again a workflow of about
four days
i'm going to start with the open array
workflow and for
some of you this may be very familiar uh
open array
represents what we would call a
mid-density
genotyping platform and it defines
really i think the largest
user group in a family of technologies
supporting pharmacogenetics today for
routine testing
as i mentioned in the slide prior
open array technology is primarily a
genotyping workflow
and you have a separate 384-well
workflow to support
copy number variation analysis to create
a full panel offering
so the pros here is that you have as low
as a four-hour
workflow from sample extraction to
result for just genotyping
the cons are that you would have to take
into consideration a separate workflow
for copy number variation
um in a 384 well uh pcr plate format
and if you wanted to add hla this would
require yet
a separate technology in sanger
sequencing
um to support an hla component for a
panel
so as you can see a platform selection
really has
a tremendous bearing on the type of
panel you can deploy
the time to result here a cost
per result which i'll talk about in a
moment
and uh and uh in an overall workflow
a little bit about the architecture of
the array for those who are unfamiliar
the open array can be formatted for
genotyping drawing from
a library of several million
pre-designed assays this is the tacman
genotyping assay portfolio
and in through a web-based formatting
application
that can be found on the thermo-fisher
scientific website
we can format this array drawing from
that content
in one of five formats so i can build an
array with 26
pharmacogenetic assays of interest
60 120 180 or 240
but as i described before open array is
is
is um much more relevant at 120 markers
and below
and if we look at these formats for
genotyping
we can see that at 26 markers we can
assay 96 samples
per run at 60 markers we can have say 48
at 120 markers
we can ask a 24 marker or 24 samples
per run the instrument the quant studio
12k
real time pcr instrument can thermal
cycle up to four
arrays every three hours so you can see
the sample throughput is pretty
significant
but we have to take that sample
throughput in the context of other panel
content
that would invoke other workflows like
copy number variation or hla
so our limiting factor would be defined
by
the lowest volume workflow
in that overall panel content
deliverable
for copy number variation analysis
workflow we draw from about one and a
half million
copy number variation assays that are
tiled across the entire human genome
now for applied testing we would
restrict consideration largely to sip
2d6 for pharmacogenetic application
and we have assay content that would
satisfy
a panel build for that type of
deployment
but again this would be a separate
workflow in a 384-well plate
i want to contrast the workflow that i
just described
in qpcr with microarray workflows
and i'm going to talk about two
different panel deployments
one is the axiom pharmacoscan array
versus the axiom pharmacofocus array
pharmacoscan of course being a much more
broad density array again four thousand
uh
four thousand pgx markers across
genotyping copy number variation in hla
versus the pharmacofocus array which is
about 2 000 markers of high
ptx value again across genotyping
copy number variation in hla content but
as you can see
sample formats are a big delineation
here
with pharmacoscan supporting plate
formats of 24 samples or 96 samples and
pharmacofocus
supporting plate formats of from 96 to
384 samples
again we're working across the same time
to result for both formats about three
and a half days
but our sample processivity on
pharmacofocus
is um is about 4x
increased over pharmaco scan
brief overview of the workflow um just
to
help you understand how the the daily
workflow is broken down
and day one we look at a multiplex pcr
that would be a combination of targeted
and full gene pcr
that's important for the full gene uh
pcr our amplification step
to interrogate highly complex genes like
zip 2d6 or 2c19
we would go into day two where we go
through fragmentation precipitation and
a full day of hybridization
in day three we label ligate wash and
scan and we're on to analysis
i'll talk a bit about the pharmaco scan
product in greater detail
as i mentioned we're looking at in
excess of
4 000 ptx
markers of high value so tremendous
breadth
copy number variation uh in the context
of the
lcd that i brought up earlier both
pharmacoscan and pharmacofocus would be
able to fully interrogate all of that
content
for pharmaco for pharmaco scan again
we're looking at
about a thousand genes uh covering cpic
high value content
uh pharm gkb content
of the highest evidence uh value all the
way down through
research grade value this next slide
breaks down that content
further and you can see the breakout of
admi content
uh historic team plus content
farm gkb content cpic guidelines and
so a full complement of content here
certainly enough to cover
the lcd we discussed earlier
in contrast the pharmacofocus array
narrows that content down to about 2 000
relevant ptx
variants across about 150 genes
again we're able to cover that high
value hla content that was described in
the lcd
as well the copy number variation uh
targets for
sub 2d6 that were just that were
described in the lcd
as well as copy number in hl8 content
well and above
what the lcd requires
so on the previous slide i highlighted
the overall content
description for pharmacofocus looking at
2000 high-value ptx variants across
applications in genotyping copy number
variation in hla
here we just show how pharmacofocus
addresses hla content certainly
the array addresses the lcd content that
was described earlier as our use case
and lastly we'll look at how
pharmacofocus
addresses copy number variation as you
can see
it addresses copy number variation for
genes well beyond
critical genes such as sip 2d6
which we described earlier as essential
for deployment for a note for the lcd
panel
that we saw earlier in the slides
so pharmaco focus interrogates
gene copy numbers for gstm1 utt2b17
salt1a1 to name a few
so taken together we've discussed two
technologies
qpcr-based technology that is fast but
is limited
uh compared to microarray and
application scope
and microarray technology that is broad
in content deployment
and certainly sufficient for the lcd
that we described from a panel
of support for routine testing but a bit
slower from the standpoint of return to
results
we've talked about content flexibility
overall workflow
again time to results it's important
that we highlight cost it's a key driver
so as a family open array
as a family of technologies that we
described as mid density
uh qpcr based platforms there are
several
open arrays one has
set the standard for being the really
the the most broadly used platform
technology in the marketplace for
routine testing
and as a family the community has become
used to
the testing community has become used to
a return of results between one to three
days depending on the breadth of
application
uh supported for panel they're used to
content
customizability and of which
all three use cases we described can
support
they're used to a price point for 120
markers and below of right around thirty
dollars per sample
pharmacoscan as the higher density
offering in the microwave family
offers at price point per result around
75 dollars per sample and below
what's important to note is that
pharmacofocus really bridges
these two family of products microarray
and qpcr
in that it offers a price point for
marker content that we describe of right
around
thirty dollars a sample and that means
as
a technology that had historically been
relegated to high density testing it's
now moved into this
higher volume mid-density family of
technologies
so hopefully i've been help i've been
able to help you understand some of the
selection criteria that we see the
the community using to pick technologies
we've talked a little bit about emerging
technologies and how
they're changing the dynamic of use of
technology in pharmacogenetics
and i thank you for your time